Being a video archivist for the SCP Foundation
is one of the easiest jobs in the entire organization.
You’re responsible for viewing every tape
found in the field, every interview with an
anomaly, and every event log recorded by a
Mobile Task Force.
If something passes your desk, that means
the Foundation’s going to want its contents
viewed, transcribed, and the original source
footage stored for preservation.
Compared to the doctors working tirelessly
to push their research to the boundaries of
understood science and field agents risking
their lives elsewhere, your job of lounging
in an air-conditioned room, sitting at a computer
and watching videos all day seems pretty appealing.
At least, on paper it does.
When you take into account just what it is
you’ll be transcribing, the grim realities
present in all Foundation careers start to
emerge in your deceptively cushy office gig.
It’s no secret that the Foundation’s visual
logs describe unspeakable horrors within.
Disgusting body alterations, gorey details,
and terrifying imagery are mainstays of Foundation
files.
Most are never conscious of the fact that
every log that’s been written out had to
have been viewed by someone in the first place.
Those blank Redacted areas where your imagination
has to fill in the details?
Somewhere, someone in the Foundation had to
transcribe that sensitive information in the
first place.
That gruesome kill in the Task Force report?
The visual archivist saw the footage before
they wrote it out.
Sure, your job might be to watch the Foundation’s
home movies all day, but due to the sheer
amount of visual materials the Foundation
needs to transcribe and catalogue, you’ll
on average be seeing far more horrors than
the typical researcher or task force member.
Instead of being assigned to one or two projects
at a time, you’ll witness an infinite slew
of footage from across the Foundation’s
history.
You’ll just be viewing all of the horror
from a distance, behind a screen, after the
fact.
But you don’t need to be told that.
You’re a professional, hard-boiled, grizzled
veteran of the Foundation.
You watch hours of footage a day, transcribe
it, archive it, and send it out to be inserted
in the various articles and files in the Foundation
database.
You’ve lived through countless Task Force
missions, observed endless testing logs, and
seen everything from unimaginable entities
to the bloodiest events ever taken place.
It used to keep you up at night, but at this
point, you’re desensitized to almost anything
the world can throw at you.
Maybe that’s why you were the Foundation’s
latest choice to transcribe the footage recovered
from the site of SCP-6670.
You’d heard the stories.
A series of tapes that other archivists were
flat-out refusing to transcribe, due to sheer
disgust and horror.
They’d been passed down the line two or
three times, and now they came to you, in
a box of literal VHS tapes labeled with a
strip of tape that read “SCP-6670, RECOVERED
MEDIA”.
You didn’t doubt that whatever was on these
was intense, since it was enough to get a
few Foundation archivists to pass, something
that rarely happens, but you were sure they
weren’t anything you couldn’t handle.
You inspect the box for a manifest paper to
see if you can gain any other information
about the tapes.
Most of the time, the varying parts of the
Foundation’s research is kept heavily indiscernible
from one another.
The right hand never knows what the left is
doing, so getting any further context to the
footage you’re about to review is oftentimes
necessary.
But the paper inserted on top of the box doesn’t
reveal much.
It reads: “Footage recovered from the discovery
site of SCP-6670, Containment Site 86, Detroit,
Michigan”.
That’s about as much as you’re going to
get, but at least it’s something.
You take the tape that says “First” on
it, and pop it into the VCR.
Yeah, you had to dust off that old dinosaur
just for this.
The real anomaly is that it still works after
all these years.
The first tape is overlaid with a title that
takes up the entirety of the screen.
“HAPPY BIRTHDAY JEMMA!
1988” it reads.
The camera pans to a small infant laying down
on a cushion.
You can tell from the brief glimpses of the
background that the house is dilapidated,
poorly held together.
Not the conditions a child should be raised
in, but an unfortunate reality that some face.
The baby stares at the camera, wiggling and
making adorable baby noises.
You wonder if this is Jemma, the birthday
girl herself.
Your thoughts are confirmed by the camera-holder,
who plays with and tickles Jemma, celebrating
her birthday.
The camera-holder asks the baby to “smile
for mommy”, which little Jemma gleefully
does.
Of course, the one holding the camera is Jemma’s
mother, and the two are celebrating her first
birthday.
The rest of the tape is ordinary, with Jemma
and her mother playing and laughing together.
Her mother sings happy birthday to her, and
the recording stops.
Well, that wasn’t so bad, you think to yourself.
In fact, taking into account most of the stuff
that passes your desk, that was pretty good!
But that was only the first tape.
You’re intrinsically drawn to the next one,
wondering how this could possibly inspire
so much fear in the others who watched it.
Second tape.
The shot opens up with a woman dressed in
slightly tattered, sewn together, formal attire.
She’s filming herself standing before a
mirror.
The title reads “JOB INTERVIEW PRACTICE
TAPE”.
After the title disappears, she begins talking
to herself.
She reveals her name, “Melanie Jamie G.
Parker”, and acts as if she’s applying
to a job.
Specifically to an internship at the Walter
Media Broadcasting Company.
You can tell from the sound of her voice that
this is Jemma’s mother.
Melanie’s mock-interview proceeds slowly.
She’s visibly apprehensive, chokes over
her words, and seems to be in great distress.
Melenie mentions that she turned 18 the other
day, and that she’s interested in applying
for a job as a news reporter.
Still, she can’t get the words out properly,
stuttering and hesitating.
She’s clearly distracted by something off-camera.
Midway through her rehearsal, the sound of
high-pitched crying is heard.
It’s the baby.
Melenie assures Jemma that she’s coming,
and leans over to hit the button to stop the
recording before rushing off to calm down
the crying child.
Again, nothing horrible, you think.
It’s difficult to watch someone so young
struggle with the challenges of motherhood,
but it hasn’t made you lose your lunch or
anything.
You take out the third tape, pop it in, and
see what happens next.
Another title: “A LETTER TO MY FAMILY [CUT
THIS]”
Seems like it was intended to be thrown out.
The picture comes in, showing a crying Melenie,
sitting on the edge of her bed in a white
gown.
Sniffling up her tears, Melenie delivers a
message intended to be viewed by her family.
You learn that her relationship with them
is unstable, and that Melenie has been on
her own for months, potentially longer.
She musters out an apology to her parents,
saying that she’s sorry about everything,
for a party, for stealing their money.
She continues to cry, but tells them that
she wants them to know that she’s sorry,
and that she loves them.
She addresses her sister’s caring attitude,
and her mother’s smile, but is hesitant
to compliment her father.
She reveals that she hasn’t spoken to them
in two years, but she can’t go any longer.
She’s barely been able to afford basic necessities,
and despite applying for as many jobs as she
could, she hasn’t landed one.
Her personal savings are almost depleted,
and she can’t sleep at night.
Jemma’s getting bigger.
A lot bigger than any girl should be at two.
She’s rapidly outgrowing her clothes, and
Melenie’s unable to provide her with the
love and care that she needs.
She’s halfway through saying that she wants
her parents to take custody of Jemma.
But she stops.
She can’t get herself to admit it.
She stares at the camera, shakes her head,
and begins cursing.
Melenie’s voice gets louder, and she vehemently
defends her decision to keep Jemma for herself.
She’s not subjecting herself to her family,
who she clearly despises.
Melenie continues to lash out against her
family, saying that she’s tired of them,
and that they will never find her and Jemma.
She’s visibly shaking, her voice unstable.
Melenie’s made her decision - Jemma’s
staying with her.
She makes a statement:
“You should’ve seen how happy Jemma and
I were, how nice life is out here.
The sun’s so much brighter, there’s no…
no fighting.
No screaming.
No… crying.
I took my daughter and I left all of you and
I am happy.”
In the background, Jemma’s crying is heard
again from another room.
Melenie, drained, looks in the distance, surprised
to hear that she’s awake.
She wipes the tears from her eyes and assures
Jemma that her mother will be right there.
She forgets to turn the camera off, and rushes
out of the room.
For the rest of the tape, lasting nearly two
hours in duration, Melenie calms Jemma.
Holding her and assuring her that she’s
safe.
Eventually, the camera’s battery gives out
and the recording stops.
So far, it’s definitely upsetting to see,
but you haven’t encountered anything anomalous
yet.
Maybe the fourth tape will shed some light
on what’s going on here.
You put it in, and prepare for the worst.
This tape cuts in immediately, without a title.
Jemma and Melenie are playing together in
Melenie’s bedroom.
What she said about Jemma’s growth is true.
She’s only two, but she stands at four feet
tall, with long and disheveled blonde hair.
Jemma runs across the bedroom, making noises
and pretending to be an airplane.
Melenie, for once, doesn’t seem to be stressed,
though she looks visibly tired.
The sound of a phone ringing is heard in the
background.
Melenie immediately snaps out of her happy
attitude and runs off to answer it.
While she talks on the phone, Jemma is seen
peering into a small hole in the wall of the
bedroom.
She then moves offscreen.
While Melenie is talking on the phone, Jemma
tries to get her mother’s attention.
When Melenie hangs up, she notices that she
doesn’t see her daughter anywhere, and begins
frantically searching.
Jemma answers, her voice coming from inside
the hole in the wall.
Melenie tries to goad her child from outside
the wall, but Jemma doesn’t listen.
Eventually, she hears a loud snap, and then
a scream.
Melenie panics, moving her head into the hole.
Jemma cries, screaming that she’s in pain
and that she hurt something.
Melenie tells her that she’ll get help,
and desperately tries not to panic.
She runs offscreen, and for fifteen minutes,
all that’s heard is Jemma’s crying.
Melenie returns with a young man, who would
later be identified as her neighbor, John
Bates.
He carries a rope.
Melenie directs Bates to the hole in the wall.
The two are clearly familiar with one another,
and Melenie assures Jemma that “Mr. John”
is going to help her out of the hole.
Bates kneels on the floor and inserts his
head into the wall, feeding the rope inside
the hole.
On the count of three, they tell Jemma to
grab the rope, and they’ll pull.
Seconds pass without a response, and suddenly,
Bates feels a tug.
She’s grabbing the rope.
Melenie and Bates pull together, hoping to
lift Jemma out of wherever she fell, but the
girl won’t move.
She continues to say that she’s stuck.
And neither Bates, nor Melenie can get her
to budge.
Melenie, who is now crying, assures Jemma
that they’ll get her out, while Bates is
more reluctant.
Bates tells her that they aren’t going to
be able to get her out by themselves, and
the two begin to argue loudly.
They agree to call the fire department, after
all, they’re specialized in getting people
out of confined spaces.
Bates tries calling, but the lines are full.
Meanwhile, Melenie continues to lose hope.
Bates insists that they have to call 911,
but Melenie knows she doesn’t have enough
to cover medical costs, and if they discover
the living conditions that Jemma’s been
in, they’ll surely take her child away.
The two continue to argue.
Bates suggests that Melenie phones her family,
which is the ultimate breaking point for her.
From offscreen you can hear a struggle.
The sound of a cupboard opening, and then
Bates hitting the floor.
Thirty minutes of silence follow.
When Melenie returns, she's caked in dirt,
grease, and blood.
What happened was evident.
Melenie sticks her head inside the hole in
the wall, and assures Jemma that her mother
will take care of her.
The next tape pulls you in.
The title displays: “HAPPY BIRTHDAY JEMMA
1991”.
You recognize that the video is being taken
from inside the wall.
There’s a small lava lamp, and a cupcake
with a candle in front of Jemma, who lays
prone on the ground.
She’s more pale than before, and looks to
be about 5 feet tall now, and her shoulders
encompass the length of the space.
From behind the camera, Melenie sings to her,
and Jemma blows out the candle.
The recording stops.
Another tape.
“HAPPY BIRTHDAY JEMMA 1993”.
Jemma’s looking visibly ill.
Her eyes droop, she smiles tiredly, and her
body seems to be larger than the space its
confined to.
A cake sits in front of her with five candles.
Melenie sings to her again.
The 1997 birthday tape is even worse.
Jemma is about 7 feet tall, and her face encompases
the entire hole, with no discernible head.
Melenie sings to Jemma, who just wants to
eat her cake.
The sound of Jemma’s bones clicking and
cracking as her body contorts to the tight
space is heard.
The next tape is unlabeled, but the Foundation
determined it to be recorded around 2001.
Melenie sits outside the door to her bedroom,
sobbing.
Her bedroom is entirely inaccessible.
Behind the door, the cracking of bones is
heard throughout the house.
She’s singing happy birthday to Jemma, who
is unseen.
Jemma’s voice can be heard, begging for
food.
Another crack, this time from the ceiling.
Dust falls from above, the house is giving
out.
Jemma screams that she’s in pain, and that
she doesn’t want to fall.
The cracking gets louder, and before Melenie
can finish singing, she’s taken back by
the horror of the situation.
Jemma begs her mother to help her, and that
her back hurts.
The ceiling’s about to give out any second.
And suddenly, it does.
The camera tips, showing a ceiling full of
cracks, which give out over the next few seconds.
Melenie screams that she’ll catch Jemma,
but she’s simply too big.
Her form is revealed.
A block of barely human skin and tissue, shaped
into a square mass due to being confined to
the walls for years.
You can’t tell that the entity before you
is still human, and most of all, an injured,
scared child.
Jemma’s anomalous growth, when confined
into such a small space over a long period
of time, resulted in this.
Jemma falls to the floor, crushing Melenie
in the process.
For the remaining four hours of the tape,
Jemma sifts and struggles, all while crying
out for her mother.
The tape stops.
Disturbed by the content, you know you’re
going to feel sick transcribing these tapes.
You check the corresponding database file
for SCP-6670 in hopes you can access it.
Thankfully, its within your clearance, and
all is illuminated when you read what’s
already there.
SCP-6670 is Jemma, described as a large, amorphous
entity made of flesh, tissue, and contorted
bones.
SCP-6670 is confined to a small house in Detroit,
Michigan, where its been contained on-site
with a concrete wall constructed around the
home.
SCP-6670 was discovered following the recording
of the tape, when passersby outside the house
described the structure as “breathing”.
After which, containment measures were implemented
and research began.
The only access point to SCP-6670 is through
the doorway outside the bedroom, as most of
the house’s structure is either destroyed
or taken up by SCP-6670’s mass.
X ray scans revealed that SCP-6670’s spine
is extremely contorted and is assumed to have
grown along the dimensions of the home, with
puberty assumed to have accelerated the growing
process.
SCP-6670 is largely immobile, and is believed
to be “hibernating”.
Its intelligence seems to be roughly equivalent
to a small child.
Inside the home, the tapes were found, and
the file describes them as awaiting transcription,
which is your job.
Beneath the section intended for your work,
is an event log, transcribed by personnel
working on site with SCP-6670.
The entity, after remaining immobile for so
long, had eventually moved.
The log read as follows:
“The entity rolled in front of the camera,
where its mouth could be seen.
It’s surrounded by several strings of rotting
flesh and caked with blood.
The teeth are rotten, consistent with typical
patterns of tooth decay.
A clump of black hair clings to the side of
its lower lip.
SCP-6670 is heard speaking.
The camera registers the sound as similar
to ”Mama, I’m hungry.”
Its voice is that of a young girl.”
You’re taken back by the graphic bodily
alteration described, when the realization
hits you that you’re going to have to watch
these tapes multiple times over to ensure
proper transcription.
But then one other thing stands out.
A clump of black hair on SCP-6670’s lip?
But Jemma had blonde hair.
And then it hits you.
You know that you’ll be in for many sleepless
nights after this is all said and done.
Now go check out “SCP-002 The Living Room
& the Most Terrifying SCP Rooms” and “SCP-2432
- Room Service” for more super weird human
body-contorted rooms and spaces!